we are laughs welcome to the Isle North
podcast and the Lords of gimmick dotnet
episode number 113 and it's another
glorious Sunday we're back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day and today
the round will rejoice we have the
twenty three twenty nineteen prediction
series the final chapter and Microsoft
is up to bat
we've saved the very best for last and
I'm extremely proud to have all this
Xbox royalty here at the round table so
we go get right into it I want to
introduce a Lord who's not only a true
friend to the round table but walks with
the integrity and respect of the entire
gaming community this officer of the law
is one of the hardest-working content
creators in the game yet always
showcases positivity and passion for
these games we love to play introducing
that created host of the devil barrel
gaming YouTube channel the Lord remains
a true beacon of light as an xbox
ambassador and officer friendly raised
in the gritty ways of the vista league
game trade program New York City's
finest and making his return into the
realm of the Lord's mommy Lord Bulls
dick excel how you doing sir man this is
uh this is a great show to be here I
mean listen you know episode 73 is
probably from me personally a pinnacle
part in my gaming career when it comes
to you know podcasting YouTube being
content creating because I got a chance
to really get to know you guys and for
me that's probably one of the highlights
I'm gonna look back in my life and say
I'm proud to know but you know listen I
I have to say this before we go any
further you know there are a lot of
really incredible people on this panel
outside of the iron Lords which are
amazing
of course dealer gaming I'm a big fan
have been a big fan for years working
with him it's been amazing
Tim dog I mean listen the guy's a legend
I know Rand might be showing up another
guy that I really you know a couple of
19 months ago I was a guy that just
listened while I was at the gym or while
I was doing laundry I was doing stuff in
the house and the fact that I get to
work with these guys everyone on
today's panel is on absolutely an honor
but I want to say this to anyone that's
listening first of all if you're tuning
in for the iron Lords that means that
you're already subbed but if you're
tuning in for Randall 419 dealer gaming
or of course Tim dog I urge you to hit
that sub button before you get on out of
here because not only is this gonna be
an amazing show we're all friends and to
see the iron Lords grow and know that I
helped do that it makes me very happy as
a human being and I won't take up any
more time but thanks for having me do it
I really appreciate it we got family in
the realm right now we got the bosses
I'm feeling good there we go get the
show go hopefully record joint and
progress we'll see him soon I'm sure
he'll pour dinner and show up like this
way of course we have a lord whose
continued ascension as a top five
content creator is truly a sight to
behold this Lord is the epitome of PC
and console technical acumen yet always
tells it how it is with his all-star
cast of Lord J Fonzarelli Co s wit
soccer and D batch oh I thought that was
about me - you said that Oh introducing
the host and creator of the real deal
xbox podcast the Reaper of gaming and
exposure of frauds with misinformation
[Music]
now I know you're about kognito you
never exposed spice in that intro it
does catch some people off-guard but
that's Cognito also uh you know I I
agree with boom if you're tuning in we
turn this into the tradition like every
year right where we're here on the art
and I was here last year I called a cult
I guess he's sleeping Sophia if you hear
a tweet at Rand and
let him know he's the fraud but I do
want to say that it should be a
fantastic show David's got the dolls but
in the background five meter is of
course you know everything stuff off an
attic as always is hiding in a pile of
cardboard boxes so in the corner bring
me up like some of the most fun RTX
shows we have is of course feature some
of the iron Lords so we got to do that
more often we'll definitely have to do
that more often and thanks to everyone
join and hit that like button it really
helps these guys more than you know yeah
he's gonna bring some cardboard boxes
and let's get into it
they're building an absolute pleasure
you already know and of course last but
certainly not least we have one of the
last Xbox Don's at the round table Lord
of the Xbox community and with a single
tweet can galvanize the entire realm
together and make a lot of people mad
introducing the godfather of the Xbox
fan base and panelists of the txr and
RDX podcast the Lord everyone can't wait
to cross paths with it III and one of
the few survivors of the last great
console war fellow met Fame fellow
combat sports fans and the man who puts
the 42 no Xbox game studio title on the
line at e3 2019 mommy
Lord beasts fired Tim dog how you doing
sir are you doing all of the internal of
the other century I love it 14 you know
lovely get ready Rand right now you
didn't even know happy to be here
all-star panel or great people Craig
thank you for the kind words Cognito the
central in the game thank you let's get
ready to rock and roll closest at that
time of year you already know we do and
you already know we got the Four
Horsemen of gaming those original
loyalty at the roundtable my coals for
the coast my brother from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
howl of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict I don't do it pretty good
huh actually I set an alarm ran but uh
you know it don't we got a lot to talk
about today but according to the that
the title we just have the prediction to
talk about and all the guests so I guess
the gastro topics yeah II guess I'm
gonna talk about mr. boomstick for 20s
and right we predicted squeeze at the
tops is little good would you be blood
just Final Fantasy seven blaze I've been
playing that cold vein the beta - yeah
it was good he's doing his weirdo stuff
jumping in people chat and then
disappear right after what I was into
I'm sure you enjoy like you talked a lot
about that day because he complained
about and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo play who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also that sastra darkness
mr. Othman profile Illuminati and lower
patron of the iron with you guys just
every time you talk to something about
what Cognito what personal information
cognizant addressed
I actually got back into um AC Odyssey
like I've never like I've never seen a
game that overwhelming this is too much
I love clearing out the map in every AC
and this one has been an uphill battle
like it's never been every part of the
map but I've like 60 hours in it
I think I have about the same and I mean
forget I'm not even remotely close to
beat in the game but it's just like more
and more like I thought Witcher was a
lot but now this is crazy
wait did you see the jeely a man what
what's funny is that was like oh you
know I'm seen you're trying to hunt down
all the the Colt people and they're
about 20 hours doing this people you
know you have to kill them to kill beat
the Gaelic what you don't have to right
but I implore you to do so like that
game is it rewards you for doing that
and the game is it's awesome so busy
yeah and I'm a huge Assassin's Creed fan
and for something to dethrone Black Flag
is Saints game I think everything no
matter as much content as it has it does
seem like everything and upgrade stuff
like III don't like grinding stuff are
you always getting some new armor some
something cool and then I didn't realize
I don't know if this was in the game at
launch but at launch could you customize
the look of your weapon that's what's up
I got 200 hours into that game Wow
and of course you know we got the
Incredible Hulk of this a.k.a the excess
gamer ooh the lord of combat sports king
of the statues who do bears nothing less
to their premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement ooh
being loved it Lord King how you doing
sir okay I'll know what it is I'm gonna
do this to myself because a new one
you're dying on yourself for real combat
talk was supposed to be up yesterday
time cat daddy with this 20 dollar super
Chad thank you brother
III next Sunday my wedding this Saturday
after that my honeymoon be a good month
for me also anyone mad at getting passed
expanding should lick a truckstop back
dominus pencil of it yesterday I didn't
do to combat talk yesterday and you know
you know should be up or whatever
whatever and I'm like you know what the
fight is crap right um shout-out to the
man but this guy I knew when he came
over I didn't like the vibe but a fight
alright let's you have to set it up
because he was supposed to fight a big
baby Miller big baby Miller and him
would have been a better fight AJ
Anthony Joshua and um that fight was
supposed to happen it was actually a bad
energy there see I don't like these
noisy things I don't like shaking hands
in between rounds smiling at each other
good one
I don't like that crap I don't like when
you're at the press conference hi how
are you today
the hell with that I want my fighters
mean I want my fighters angry I want my
fighters yelling out stuff like I want
him to die in a ring I like stuff like
that that stuff actually motivates me
time to get out and do what I got to do
so when they weren't doing that and I
saw them coming up - The Phantom - is
gonna be one of those AJ's specials you
know he picked a cherry off the tree and
came in last night
bell went off of my head because I look
at the betting line the betting line on
the fight was twenty to one I said man
last time I saw 21 was Mike Tyson versus
Buster Douglas I said oh my god as the
fight was going on everything I said in
my head
that can't happen what happened because
in the beginning of the fight
Ruiz started hunting Anthony down
countering everything that Anthony did
now glass jaw McGraw stepped up to the
plate like he always does and he got hit
in the side of his head and is a meme
out there right now when he got his soul
left his body went back to greatest meme
I've ever seen
yes um so after giving away to myself
anybody who better dollar god bless you
anybody who bet $100 man anybody that
bet $1,000 listen call me um let me see
what we doing this week it was it was
upset yeah all right it's dead they're
gonna do the rematch and I expect
Anthony Joshua to lose again yeah
because they're gonna do it in England
you know I was gonna be in Wembley state
and he's gonna feel really good about
himself but the Michelin Man need to
slim down but muscle memory is a
beautiful thing and it was a great fight
anybody who watched it was thoroughly
entertained and if you do not like
Anthony Joshua please go watch the fight
twice though I had to hit you they would
hit me up like yeah I need that kick
analysis right quick my PMS is going so
nuts I'm watching the fight and my dm's
is going crazy people calling me fraud
it was like where's combats unfair of
course we got you know the Lord kognito
of the cooperative experience in the
building not much gaming going off me
man prepping for e3 shout to just go and
already know what type of situation here
you know say we're getting crap
everybody's getting those appointments
but enough about all that you know
saying we here to get into these topics
the reason why we are here
yeah it's time to talk about this thing
of ours we got it every time I look back
at the screen somebody's wearing
something different
Lord random fortunately it's been
whacked Excel you know the rising
double-barrel gaming family of course
Lord deal of the feared RDX family and
of course we have the dawn The Godfather
Lord Tim dogs keys for some Lord
Tim dog you know we gotta talk about the
state of the streets are talking hard
you just got your new phone this ain't
Sony is already won III must depending
release dates so let's talk about what's
going on Microsoft now we feel going
forward the floor is yours
they dawn Tim dawn well I think their
their shuttle to prove what they're
about you know they're either gonna flop
or they gonna you know they this is
their show they gotta think about a
hundred percent take it to them and my
bar is high for them I don't think that
you can when you have comments like Phil
said I think feel kind of put a lot of
pressure himself with the 1442 no
comment or the 14 in your comment that's
gonna be a dissected but the floor is
theirs and I expect them to hit all the
right notes and I expect them to do a
good job here
expecting it hey so you feel it but like
just overall totally nineteen how we
feel it like what are you good good I
feel like that we're like for Xbox
they're on the verge of like like really
setting forward
they're quite not right there but this
is the start of it this is where they
gotta make their play they have
obviously their whole generation has
been an extremely tough generation on
them they've done a lot of things to
improve the Xbox brand they've done a
lot of things to set themselves up for
the future you know it's just now it's
about execute it's a it's like from even
what they said they've done the time for
talk is over is always now about
execution know down and the starts with
this III you know I don't know your guys
expectations is both my expectations
pretty high I want them to announce that
they're you know you know will go into
protection somewhere I want them to to
tell their story to be full of bravado
and you know you know be there and be
there in a big way this is just like
pull out all door stops this is the time
where you got the you know do the job
like yeah we got some talk to you like I
still got faith to fill but you know it
was it was a time where there was a
little doubt a lot of Xbox guys and
that's it - 7 - 2017 even though they
had a pretty good show but now is the
time I think what year was that Tim that
was a doughnut wall yeah you know was
the year where they really have any big
closed on a multi-platinum
you know was the Scorpio reveal I think
but it was just more or less than
showing the games and that was like
their their time when you know for that
final super chat Lord to meet this
right-handed Zeus's entered the room was
good friend that's my black brother
shoutout to what's going on see you and
Kelly my friend no way big brother Wade
you know Yuri no so let's get a lore
dealer in here we'll be feeling man they
saying that they say they already won
8-3 dealer they saying that last of us a
Dutch man and release dates it's over
Microsoft shouldn't even show up
hmm mind we have cringy dis community is
I somebody dudes out there that that
last year they had this they had the
dude up there with a snake-charmer music
panel before that they did have the
actual snake charmers up there they lost
a couple III s now wasn't even close
those fifty games to like you know
negative six and this year it's gonna be
even more apparently thank you so you
know we pointed out that look you got 14
first party games on the stage and from
what I hear see if these is gonna be
there so that's great Steve's ever again
I've been watching that on for five
years and I work here black in so we've
confirmed that it's not there
no I've heard that it's not there at
least it's not one of the 14 so 14 first
party games on the stage and it's like
nobody said that it's gonna be new games
in fact I'm confident most of them will
not be new games but we are excited to
see Gabe's yes that's what e3 is about
right so fun not only that you're
getting a ton of third-party as well and
the reveal of hopefully some technical
information on their new systems that I
think they need to at least match what
Sony's uh bring it to the table right
talking about the lot of times and kind
of basic specs at the very least they
need to do that but yeah they've been
pretty dominant last couple you threes
in my opinion man and and I'm very
excited to see what they bring to the
table if you see game passes ramped it
up
everybody's already on Twitter you know
dropping the hammer things are looking
good man I'm excited that Lord bull man
how we feeling coming to III Street to
talking you know the thing is this I
kind of just wanna you know because you
guys specialize in sports as well as
gaming right you know you do you do the
mixed martial arts and in sports one of
the greatest things that as fans is a
comeback okay and you we've seen it in
fighters we've seen it in football teams
we've seen it in baseball and we're
seeing it happen in gaming you know if
you and I'm gonna kind of really were
winding time for a bit you know you look
back to what happened with the ps3 right
it was a disasterous launch the price
was off the message was off and they
they turned it around towards the end of
generation and we know what you did with
the ps4 right one second let me jump to
the super chair record this is about to
get really good all right shout out the
basement radio arcade my man baby stay
do one yes and you should be there too
cuz your room was dead six six six nine
for the $9.99 super jet and King alright
I have to get the Sony III predictions
Oh shadow stay for being petty early no
values to talk about the underdog story
I mean let's see okay so you saw what
happened with the PlayStation brand
right it went from you know the dog
house to the penthouse right and you
look you look back at what Nintendo did
with the Wii U and it was a failed
system it barely broke 10 million
consoles sold and look what they're
doing with the switch right they've
quadrupled their numbers and a quarter
of the time it's just it's really great
but when you look at what the Xbox has
done what Phil Spencer and team Redmond
has put together we can't just talk
about 2019
we have to rewind this back to e3 2018
when they close that show it was an
entirely new Microsoft okay they got
they bought six different first party
studios they created another one in the
crate and the initiative and it's been
rolling ever since and you know I mean
just look at what they've done this year
that I think I think regardless of what
happens at e3 I think that the the the
highlight of this year for them is gonna
be how they shut down a lot of these
fraud sites and these podcasters about
how Sony would never work with Microsoft
and it and they're doing that and then I
was gonna follow suit as well so you
know I have big aspirations not only
because this is my first III because I'm
such a big Microsoft fan I'm expecting
them to literally completely just blow
every fan out of the water not because
they have to because they need to oh
they need to show us that they have been
listening because we have taken it
really on the chin this entire
generation as fans not just from the
horrible PlayStation toxic community but
the media I know plenty of Sony guys
that dead or Microsoft fans as well and
they don't get involved in that nonsense
that that that is the toxic community
and they do really ruin it for everyone
keeps me entertained 80% of the day okay
I mean I try to stay away from it but to
be honest with you I think that
Microsoft has absolutely no choice to
completely just let this thing go crazy
and drop as much knowledge and
information on their fans know that they
that they actually care about us than
they've ever done before and this is
their show to loose do you think you
think there's no choice this year and I
think if anything I mean technically
they have I think that most more
profitable than ever so yes they don't
give like you know they don't really
care about it last I think they're doing
it because they know that they should
more than
think not because they don't have a
choice you know I mean that makes sense
I mean they are making money dealer and
you are 100% right that I care about
their like running the software it would
mean zero to me but we've seen them
double the studios like you said every
studio is hiring I'm hearing they're
build another studio yeah you know like
that stuff is that's the stuff I do like
so if you can tell me hey look we're
more profitable than we ever ever been
even though we're dead xbox Xbox dead
that's kind of odd to me for one but
have you been you can say hey we're more
profitable than ever and we're also
doubling our capacity that means that's
good that's reinvestment no doubt no
doubt Lord addict how we feeling coming
in to eat three state of Xbox look man
all they have to do is show me that
fable on the screen oh my god they won
next year and they won the year so just
for something we already know is that
mean I really think you know what dealer
said is probably what's going on they're
doing it and I think they're doing it to
to change the perspective of their brand
in the gaming industry like they might
be making money in the financial aspect
but you know let's the the media likes
clowning on them you know the hardcore
fans on Twitter like clowning on them so
I think they're trying to like you know
change that perspective as well because
you know the media we all know yeah the
media a lot of it's warranted I mean
listen me I know that's what I just said
the media perspective is not the enemy
here I mean
I think all that [ __ ] some of its
more - oh my bag you know dollar ja ja a
lot of its warranted you know and that's
why Microsoft have gotten better in fact
I've seen a lot of positive upswing you
know you guys may agree since the Xbox
one even came out or the X their goal
right now is to not give anyone ammo to
derail the launch that's that's great
point already that strand has got a
release date don't think that lasting
perfect the last thing the attic said is
perfect he's like they need to not give
anybody ammo to derail the launch of
this system so last in that sense what
boom said about it being sort of
imperative that they come out guns
blazing it's kind of true because
they're trying to sell you on a new
platform for next year so they have to
really show I think they have must fold
right it doesn't matter what we're gonna
be gonna be there day one we're gonna
pick up this machine and whatever
whatever game's gonna be available for
it it's a matter of trying to sell other
people people that have left the Xbox
fold maybe to come back and so you have
to really that we have to show there's
no question about it it put up a shut up
um I like dealer said I do sort of agree
that I don't know that that 14 may be
filled with a lot of stuff that we
already know it's coming um so I just
hope everything that surrounds it just
shows that that what they've been
talking about is willingness to - now
you know show new things and and and
hopefully and it's something that I've
always called them out on this whole
fear that they've sort of had about not
announcing stuff early pushes it has to
go in the bushes they have talked about
not down the line you know you have to
be confident enough in your Studios that
these games are gonna come out because
that's how you keep people engaged
that's how you keep people excited you
don't you know regurgitating the same
thing for two threee threes until the
game comes out people can get sort of
tired of that stuff you need to hear
about the new stuff so I'm sure you
don't want to see these for five years
in a row now
I agree Phil said what he said do you
think that that that means he's really
just really confident cuz that's a bold
statement that's a very see but that
it's a boat and we have 14 titles to
show that we both better result here
that play there are words that they're
famous for getting it's a little bit of
fluff in there or too much fluff and
that's for me really I think you do that
you should announce table votes at later
but if it's too much too much fluff this
is typical of what they do we see that
but Tim you do know that you know
obviously they were kind of little they
weren't keen on showing things too early
because the scalebound think is a
crackdown thing because these thing but
is only one of those studios was was
first party and it was underfunded they
only had a hundred people at rare at the
time and maybe now that they've got
there they're a little bit more in
control now what's happening did they
maybe they could be a little more out
and showing you some things well we know
we know they have the goods it's just
that I think hold all y'all we got five
bucks in deal his name for the swear jar
they have the goods but you have to
maybe be a little bit risky and
announced maybe something that's a
little too three years out it's only did
it work for them I just think this is
their chance to maybe do that I know
they got burned by scalebound I know
they got burned by crackdown but like
you said those were different you know
different
they got burnt by fable legends they got
different time no funding I got some
people are Microsoft at the time that
didn't want to give Xbox any money and
those people are gone so we can move
forward people in here please hit that
like button y'all the mob is in here we
don't like put a hat exactly but if it
had
at least you got to give me that come on
oh that's a car that's after 28 hours of
art right there you know good because we
got to get the King ham if you all
finished up on your own you're yourself
Lord King
let's talk that talk man stay to this
day I've been waiting for this by the
way as the person who named the xbox
only begotten Son Lord feel Dominus
and the name sticks you know a name
trick I'll talk it's not your world we
should be able right now so being that
you know I kept the light on when a lot
of dudes was out here you know Freud and
talking about all Xboxes knees his weak
xbox is this an xbox is dad I'm like I
know where the old boy had up against
him I knew just like dealer just
mentioned you know dealer has the facts
and I like the way he lays it down you
know he was underfunded a lot of these
studios were a third man and he was like
in the wind storm trying to make it
through and we saw rays of hope going
through and I've always sought a vision
and I've always stuck true to it you can
go back to any podcast any day I stood
right behind the doing 100% anytime by
somebody told him was weak but I was
like but it was this dough like um I
asked him when I had a chance to ask
some you know face to face low expenses
you know why why did you end on this
because when I shook his hand I did I
was a fraud that day you know I said in
front of him he was like how do you like
the show I said it was like it was great
it was great let's get you up he said no
shook my clothes what you really really
thought about it's really good yeah okay
why the hell did you end or somebody
else's IP business mm-hm
and I said exactly that's exactly I said
I had to hear from you mm-hmm I had to
hear from you to know
he gambled on anthem and nobody's gonna
look at that to say yo you know a bit a
lot of y'all frauds get no dad everybody
your wallet and then he gambled on
anthem - and it failed it failed but you
want him to take these Gamble's one him
to be that dude when he jumped on that
stage last year told him I said swag a
different Tim he got out this wagon he
had he was out this is gonna be a good
show it was a damn good show and I
wanted a slow bill everybody gotta come
out and they gotta throw hands and no no
I wanted a slow build game after game
after game yeah I wanna see see a thief
with the Kraken
so he's behind me he's like three rows
behind me shows been good up to now and
you know you all know that there was
just pressure and then gears comes out
and they show tears tactics everyone's
like walk air with it then they show
gears pop and everyone's like in in like
the state of mind like like what's going
on here this is really cheesy and I hear
King David and he was still staying true
he's like he said he says like you know
he's like you just got the right moment
saying you can't worry then the gayest
thing something that gets him in the
real bomber railway air yes I do I do
because you said something like dudes
like nobodies like Jeezy and I gave it
and they're like right after that he
said something gears comes on I gotta
believe that he's gonna come through any
time somebody takes the narrative cuz
remember he gotta sat on his Laurel
unless be 720p remember that 720p
madness that you had to walk around with
your head down like this about games now
guys it's time he built the machine he
built it he literally change the
narrative yeah but see like I like I
like crackdown I like the end of another
guys it was another guy's errands right
that was his last game that he put out
and he saw that through and and that's
that was very nice of him cuz he came
dropped in and threw it in the bushes it
came out and we got these games go
forward I can't wait to see what a crowd
relates to do game looks like cuz it
better look like like one of these Sony
games graphic fidelity is there it has
to show when you're gonna get a 5 is
gonna crush games like visually I don't
think people just know how good this
game is gonna look you better count I
mean if you really don't they ought to
give 5 and you know what he did
originally to get tears war up was this
is like 2014 they announced it they got
right on that studio he basically built
an engine and built a game and came out
two two and a half years you know now he
has an engine plagued and he has three
years so now yeah he did they had to
build the tech they had to learn I'm
real engine for they had to hire and
they did it all in two and a half years
with a 250 man or 230 man team now
they're up around 300 they they already
know our religion for they got the tech
built all right they got all the actors
they got the story and they got three
years mm-hm and they got the Xbox one X
from launch so this game you're gonna
blow people away is no real quick we got
to do this
first all shout out to filly eagle with
the 23 is about games not necessarily
your game but games it's impossible for
Microsoft in my opinion to fairly III
because they're gonna show games
hashtag fun is king not having fun on
the Xbox keep the narrative constant
games and fun piece is it because III
shifted to being bad about just
exclusives great cool filly ago maybe
radio so it's a game like the Avengers
we're not talking about the New Avengers
game really for the $2 super chair
salute to the iron loss panel great show
thank you so many other like we all get
into a man at the end of the day look
nobody sketching I know Alyssa you're
right dealer we a week away anything can
happen but generally Microsoft history
we've kind of get licks already now
getting a feel oh that's the whole show
but another formation campaign going on
what's happening they're releasing some
things and contradict but the Xbox one s
was leaked twelve hours before the damn
show security god I don't think that
they can make this a listen I could tell
you one thing her controlling I mean we
are we had RDX we had Mike on the show
and you could just tell he was like
what's next what's next but but yeah
they are on serious lock then this week
is the telltale sorry cuz we they could
be doing a great job and then they
something stupid given exactly and the
stuff could be shown and and we don't
want that we want to be curious which is
what's what's which is great I'm with
you Tim that's what's exciting to me
into you know to double down on your
point Tim we really hit home for me
is the fact that we didn't get any
inkling of that Sony and Microsoft
partnership we'll get into that with the
next topic but to me that was a good
sign because normally you would get a
little dribble something somebody start
talking right listen try we're going to
want his spies saboteurs you out there
too so exactly so I think I just think
that like I don't I think that the way
they did this list they pulled off the
song anything the way they did I think
these are new Microsoft I think actually
maybe NACO would fill as the the cap on
that because that was a real big problem
with that absolutely you know they would
show like they showed the gears console
before they even had the thing you've
got treehouse levels of security now
like you went to Nintendo will I listen
man we need some help
exactly so just don't talk to nobody
it's good to see you know I'm saying I'm
obviously that you know game past news
just got released everything's being
released on their cadence how they want
to do it it's interesting me seeing how
they positioning with steam that seems a
bit interesting you know yeah crazy but
um yeah and then you know reference to
the Sony thing like no disrespect to
their stranding no disrespect the last
of us to it but that don't win III for
me you know I'm saying I mean those are
great and it solidifies them for the
close of their generation but I'm
excited I'm excited about what Microsoft
has to talk about so we will get into it
and we gonna move into the next topic I
wanna own we gonna talk about that
partnership real briefly you know and
then um more so Project X cloud though
you know and it's a known next
generation so I want to get the
technical morning self-dealing to set
this off man how are we feeling about
this partnership did do you feel they
bake the need it's only been today and
then the second part is probably you
know in reference to the next generation
like how how important a factor is it to
blood
No bend the knee with me didn't he
I don't know if you could bend the knee
if you knew that it was inevitable from
the beginning right like Microsoft have
fifty billion dollars tied up into the
server network right mmm Sony aren't
worth a fraction at and it's impossible
for them to compete in the server area
they don't have the capital and even if
they did find it they would be investing
all while Microsoft will be investing as
well you would just never catch them
right so it was inevitable
they literally signed a memorandum of
understanding with Microsoft saying hey
this is what we intend to do there's a
reason we announced it it's gonna happen
and we're literally hiring Microsoft to
help us bring our games to more devices
mmm so get used to it as we told you and
well over a year ago they've already had
their games with Samsung TVs PlayStation
TVs ps3 ps4 PC and more why are people
surprised by this and now you got people
saying well it's not gonna be day and
date shouldn't you be asking for it to
be day and date the consumer stop
worrying about Sony's money but you
don't get none of and actually if you
weren't worried about some of these
money you've want this as well because
they're making more money from this
that's why they're doing it right so I
guess my question you deal with those
what about we know they had the
relationship with Amazon in the past
right so what about you know statement
that you know like why didn't they go
with Amazon as Microsoft have decades of
experience with online gaming Amazon do
not not the capacity to Xbox and and all
this stuff does definitely Microsoft are
going in a tried-and-true route with X
cloud there's a reason this is going to
be so ridiculously successful at least
in the compatibility side you've got
native hardware in the server rack if
you're an Xbox one it will work
automatically an X cloud no work from
the developer side as Mike zero RDX
right mmm it is developer agnostic we
don't have to beg developers and learn
how to do nothing and you see yeah it
even works on the on the cloud side you
don't know nothing so I think Sony are
gonna do the same thing ps4 is in the
server and you're gonna have a
PlayStation now on and all the games
which so many fans should be happy about
right just because
like question Cognito real quick cuz I
don't I'm a little I'm a little you know
I don't understand this maybe ain't
worse because it's playable in more than
one spot though you what war market
penetration you want is this is a game
better or worse because it's playable on
more than one device absolutely
alright is better it's more it's more
options for you and if you can buy one
game and get it scaled across multiple
devices that's more options for you
absolutely
so I mean at the end of the day you got
this sect if radical fanboys they've
been wrong for years we've been telling
you it's gonna happen and now they're
starting to backtrack and backpedal and
they're still acting like they have
relevant things to say just stop like
you're done you can take it down a shout
out to Daddy fat stacks for the fight I
love super chadway phil was underfunded
under cut under ate it and still prevail
like a building I feel you deal how you
talking that talk I see what you're
saying it and your importance too long I
mean something might be Dan because it
is antiquated thinking it's yeah it's
it's what the past used to be in a lot
of people we told people in ILP this is
the direction this is going and
everybody thought it was just gonna be a
Microsoft direction so then when we saw
the Sony implementation of the same you
know Sony of the ones doubling down on
console gaming not Microsoft but see the
thing Sony's been doing it for years and
people chose to not acknowledge the
PlayStation now don't act like I wasn't
purchased for the same exact reason it
just didn't work out that way yep right
it was a failed prospect and they're not
gonna talk about that ago that well that
was in the bushes you know that that's
yeah we're gonna leave that over there
never know
look at it y'all didn't want Sony to
keep dumping money into a failed project
right so you look at the market leaders
and you said to yourself okay who is
aligned their self with us basically the
Xbox one and the PlayStation 4 has same
internals inside basically like for the
Jaguar cause right so you say going
forward they're using AMD technology
wouldn't you align yourself with people
that are using similar technology to
yourself and I'll showing you that they
can do it in a positive and a prosperous
way and it's financially they're gaining
because Microsoft now essentially I want
to worry about dollars Microsoft was
matching them dollar for dollar this
generation with having half the system
sold with and less exclusives like these
guys are saying yeah we like software
right right how you say how the hell did
they do this and and you're seeing that
the rows are leading to all digital
every people on this panel has one all
digital I'm still engaged we talk about
[Laughter]
really great part of the show dealer
kills it
King David kills it more the whole
argument right there is made and the
whole history behind it or everything
that's going on with it
bottom line is is that why did they
choose Amazon why didn't they choose
Google where they talks with both of
them in the short wire and that's what I
think the PlayStation employees were
thinking that they were gonna get no
this is real talk like they were gonna
get signed on with them but the bottom
line is I think dealers right when he
says they're gonna put blades in the
India's or servers and they're gonna do
exactly what X clouds doing the reason
being they choose Xbox is because the
Xbox has some underlying technology that
makes the latency really low and you
know they are they're really doing a
great job on that
technical fronts and Sony knows it so
Sony's is caught between you two don't
have it for the next generation say I'm
a dedicated console traditional Guinea
mean who wants to game outside of your
house traditionalists you know they
ignored that argument and just not even
invest any money which who knows might
have worked but they said you know what
let's take a frat let's let's get our
own cloud solution let's be able to say
hey the guy from Xbox does it the guy
from Sony can do it because you know
what Sony has everything well you know
Tim with Tim when once I give you the
option to stream you know that normal
console stops working right at Burson
the point is that's a good thing and I
actually I used to not like Sony I'll be
honest there was a fan of their company
but there that move made me a respecter
of their company and like I said I would
put money in the company now because
that's a smart move maybe what's best
for their consumer right exactly what
the Sony fan why Tim undermine the value
of their console sovereign as they need
to feel vindicated yeah exactly need to
feel that that purchase was worth it
yeah they need to go outside more you
know you know show up you know only
three and now this year they don't care
about it it's irrelevant so and one of
the theories it was somebody on Twitter
and said this little off Facebook with
it with with their conference why they
didn't go is because they knew that they
couldn't say that there
most powerful if it was the most
powerful they'd be there a hundred
percent because they would say hey we're
the most powerful he is death stranding
and everyone say they won because people
would say 15 deaths training was coming
to PC sometime as well the last time we
talked about PC then 2015 it was coming
to PC so Tim what do you think they're
gonna have an Xbox one next I'll reveal
and they're gonna suck the wind right
out of the piece five sails again by
saying hey look we're gonna be the
benchmark as we already said yeah that's
what I'm hope
what's going on man how you feeling
about X cloud cloud infrastructure that
partnership how you feeling man well I
mean look we the thing is this obviously
there's been a significant amount of
damage control on the Sony side and for
a lot of reasons if that's your console
of choice of course you you you're gonna
you know you're gonna be upset anyone I
don't say there's anyone that says it's
okay for them they mean to miss III the
biggest show in the gaming world as we
know it is full of s I'm sorry
end of story because then you're you're
telling your company it's that it's okay
for them not to care I don't want to
hear about this oh they don't have they
don't have games to show
listen Sony control game twenty years
from now and they'll win 20 games 20
years out and they've won easier you
don't want to set like a new standard
yes absolutely and they've done it for
years and you know what listen I'm a
Sony I love Sony I love i but i play my
console for their first parties only
that's one reason why I have a console
because I enjoy their single-player
narrative games that you and we simply
put and I think everyone has already
alluded to this the reason why they
didn't go with Amazon and they didn't go
with Google is because quite frankly the
technology is in Microsoft's favor
that's why they wanted to go with
someone that one and you know what they
tried doing themselves investing 380
million dollars into Gaikai and guess
what that got them nothing this one no
stop damage controlling be happy a happy
gamer be a happy PlayStation gaming
knowing that your games are going to run
on
the best servers although world okay and
and the other thing I kind of want to
throw in there I hope that PlayStation
does their own Xbox game pass because I
will sign on for that in a second
getting getting day games day and date
first party games is something that they
get you know day meaning the PlayStation
fan base should warn because I want it
way boom boom did you just say you want
game I'm telling you game pass is gonna
be over there one of these days and I
want y'all to look back at this show
yeah okay remember when it shows up on
your box who said I mean I already said
it himself
I want this anywhere that will have it
yes that's all it's completely up to
Sony and boom are you sure you want this
day and day cuz if you get a day and
date the game sucks
shut the filly go define our super chat
to the fan boys and girls your fun
validate your purchase not ratings now
boxes not scores your fun if you aren't
having fun go green oh my - this yeah
you know it's it's pretty ridiculous
when you know cuz King was talking about
surly about monies right about how much
money's Microsoft is making hand over
fish with their services you know people
need to understand that console sale is
an antiquated way of thinking okay
that's the old guard
they have been retired now okay number
is that matter or how many copies of
Gears of War sells so if you only have
it on two places it's gonna sell 9 to 10
million but if you have that a game of
everywhere and let's say it's launching
on Steam day and date you have the
potential to sell millions upon millions
of extra copies that you were not going
to sell so people have to understand
that the services in the game sales the
actual software sales is what drives
companies profits at knott's non console
sales I don't understand why people keep
saying Oh
200 million consoles were the best
that's fantastic no one's taken away
from Sony but no all the way you're
thinking earth the sir said nah y'all
been strict he said I see the final
stage of accepting we accept we've been
you got me accepted soon - when God
Awards on my cell phone buddy understand
just like cross-play like your games
going to multiple devices explain this
real quick consoles sold is a reason
that even Sony is starting to use to
move to user base right Phil's Damon's
control when he did it right but it's
only gonna do it themselves and this is
why a console is just a big expensive
vehicle they gotta sell you something
tell you what really makes them the
money the gas which is the key they
don't care if you buy xx device or what
Y device all right my games they don't
care where you play them games is what
makes them the money if they can put
them of a moment window store they can
put them on Xbox eight Rosie you know
it's not what do you think a phone that
you buy in five years a new iPhone what
is it gonna look like that 5g holidays
nobody was seen I mean we just saw on
the last Sony investors relations call
they literally had that talked about how
she's mean to their vision for the
future the five-year the five-year plan
right to play it without even a console
quote exactly exact ending mentioned the
partnership with Microsoft as one of the
vehicles to achieve that goal and the
job listings that we told them about a
year ago exactly and I'm sorry good no I
[Music]
working and I have a you know something
of a waiver that I can't talk about it
but all I can say is is that my G if it
gets off if it gets off its world its
world like they said it won't be all
types of evil things just 5g obviously
this this tech is is something that that
requires no wires their stall
anywhere and if you know the bottom line
is everything is evolving and it's just
not more about a console that you put in
second for now I say you have a native
experience you realize they'll always be
a native experience until the cloud can
exceed it
I'd say that's 10 to 15 years away no
doubt your perfectly worded solve can
you get that super Chesser yes sir we
have a $40 super tech buy a new
subscriber gamer by choice thank you sir
this is the all-star game of podcasting
I subscribe to everyone before the show
but if you haven't you should these guys
the true game was much respected 80
people in here like when I hit that
subscribe you know Lord addict man way
yet with this man as far as the
partnership in ex-con I'm very curious
about you what X Club how you feel about
that oh yes it's great reception in the
box it was muted thank you yes but uh I
mean I don't really care about a club
per se but I think the reason Sony's
doing this is it's strictly precaution
it's like they know it's like Diller
said regardless what people seem to
think they don't have the money to just
liquidate and put into research and
development the you know the cloud
structure infrastructure they don't have
that they can either a risk their whole
company because PlayStation is the
center of their whole company or not try
to broaden that that streaming aspect in
five to ten years or B they can go to
the people that are doing it like it
literally happens every industry why is
people surprising people when the
like mm-hmm it was a billion dollars
addict success is anything
oh yeah I know I know uh I can't
remember where I heard that from but um
at the end of the day you know they
they're looking at it from the aspect of
like okay
it's kind of like what Microsoft was
gonna do with the VR they were saying
you know we don't we're not gonna make
our own VR we're just going to have the
Xbox capable vo obviously that didn't
happen but their way of thinking is we
don't have to research and develop we'll
just use everyone else's VR and ours
will be kept compatible with it
Sony's doing the same thing they're like
we don't need to make this
infrastructure will just use Microsoft's
and it's like I'll have one foot in the
door and one foot out the door if it's a
failing and not working so they'll just
bow out of the deal when it's over they
won't make another deal but if it works
they'll just pay them more money no it's
off we at man know this partnership and
um projects cloud is that the secret
weapon
I mean I'm super happy that they made
partnering with Microsoft I think it was
is the ideal thing to do I think I mean
you know Gaikai is nice for what it is
but whenever X pod launches that
difference in quality was gonna be more
and more evident um Gaikai is not built
to do what the cloud does Gaikai isn't a
cloud service god kai is built built
first it's at this point it's
specifically built to stream playstation
games and that's it on a point-to-point
server-to-server basis if you don't have
servers everywhere the quality is gonna
be what it is depending on specifically
depending on your internet connection
and that is it cloud is much different
cloud you can do whatever with cloud so
it was imperative that they jumped on
with somebody and I I think I said this
during the of the Nintendo prediction
show I'm happy that that it seems like
the big three are banding together on
this I'm happy that Microsoft Sony and
Nintendo are working together because
regardless of how you feel about Google
and Stadium the fact of the matter is
that they're coming and they spent a lot
of money a lot of time investing in
sabia you I'm happy that big three in
gaming are standing together again it's
just because we're gonna I don't think
anywhere any much wants to see stadia
and Google at
top of the gaming and and the streaming
yet I'm gonna definitely be there but I
don't want to see them take on Microsoft
or Sony or Nintendo I don't wanna see
that I have purchased a lot of online
crap remember that is different it's
different I know where you coming from
with this the tech is different though
and the fact is that they have money
hand over fist and they're willing to
spend it a B they made sure they put
gaming people at the front of this they
didn't put they didn't put tech people
necessarily why I brought up that OnLive
crap right the reason why I brought that
up and you and I face first we will do
the line like so we got I still got mine
I like to bring people but the thing is
fail technology we didn't want Sony to
do failed technology right they did VR
I'm so happy that they did do VR we
needed it in a console space and we
needed one of the big three two to
buckle down and take that on Sony took
that on my Microsoft went and was born
to develop cloud stuff um and you saw
pitfalls in this area he's so little
pitfalls in that area I don't think it
was a bad choice for Sony to invest only
in the VR and a little bit on this side
um I thought it was a great idea now I
was gonna get the next iteration of the
VR helmet we know in the PlayStation 5
going forward they're gonna be pushing
their VR heavy and I'm a proponent of
that I think VR is the next way for them
and I think that's great I also think
Microsoft stands on the VR as we gonna
let vive or whatever we're gonna build a
machine capable to run these things and
let them let other people put their
products on our stuff so yeah I
understand that I see going forward that
the cloud is necessary and I think X
cloud is going to be that wave
I don't think Sony made a batch yeah and
I think them coming out together
everybody's saying that yes we all in
agreement that this is the future it
helped it only helped sell the tech to
the fans right because if only one
person and I think I said this last week
if everybody had jumped on the VR
bandwagon at the same time the
PlayStation did and I mean and I mean in
the gaming space Microsoft and and
Nintendo in a real way VR would be in a
different place I'm not saying I was in
a bad place right but it would I would
think that it would the penetration in
the market penetration would be a lot
different if Microsoft and Nintendo had
jumped on at the same time with the same
fervor that their PlayStation did so the
messaging has to be unified in order for
this to work you can't think meant the
message because otherwise people can be
like not so they they don't really
believe in this right we move on to
passive we stayed on it so a little but
look at the end of the day you know
listen I highly anticipate one of my
highly anticipated announcements is that
public trial for X cloud like I'm really
done is here and I got a shout you out
Tim dog like when I saw you with the but
the 5g speeds you're like that's
exciting to me and all I see is just
imagining X cloud imagining these full
console experiences on the goal or just
even using my laptop remotely and using
it my phone as a 5g hotspot for like
game pass game sure you do that so easy
exactly the possibilities of each other
you know talking about panel like I'm
actually reading up I'm doing some like
research on it because I can mm-hmm I
have access to like you could read about
stuff for you about blades built and
stuff the technologies is really is so
awesome if it hits a walk it's just the
fact that will they build a tower or you
know that's that's the Kadena question I
don't know it's gonna happen but if 5g
hits off you're talking about what you
saw on that video with that no no no
you're talking about double that's in
some places in your phone and you'd see
same amount of speed so and and the
latency everything is is is like so so
the latency is like sub I can't give you
the number but it's it's ridiculous
it's so it's so like crazy how how much
this can can you know really do every
clowns you talk the clowns about it it's
just what I'm waiting for it to really
hit with gaming it's a match made in
heaven
exactly and again no one like deal is
saying no one's saying your console
busting the flames now that might not be
an option you know they're like this is
just future proof and everyone seeing
listen these like these example these
companies they're privy to a lot of this
data in this access there has to be a
reason people are shifting in this
direction and future proofing themselves
and all this like you know Sony you know
this has been their vision from day one
yeah they had guy car but clearly
they've made an internal decision that
this is not sufficient enough to propel
them to be prepared for this next
generation of learning they had to
partner with someone fine you're so
relevant and the Dish Network is
revolving their whole company around
that in the future right crazy it's I
can't wait till they show some of the
stuff that you know you see that in the
meetings it I see him a lot into that
and it's it's crazy it's amazing yeah I
can't wait until they all like all the
carrier's start showing what they there
is a lot that that they talk about but
there is a lot behind it like you know
you know like the way the way the
latency and everything that that's going
around like her dr is like it's it
changes we are too because you don't
even need a central processor i think
you can do it in the cloud you know i
mean you could do it like stati is doing
but do it OVR though now you you know
people worry about a caper i and stuff
like that you have something that solves
it stream you know listen to what we're
talking about sends like if somebody
heard this podcast three years if it
were from another planet
yeah but the reason we're just evolving
and sony
soda Garland they did the right thing
and i think it's the whole panel on this
like if you want a 101 on this whole
thing listen to the realist is because
so many great points absolutely there
yeah man it's exciting stuff is really
exciting as a fan of tech as a fan of
the future what could be four or five
years down the road you
again as an option you don't have to do
it but it's an option that excites me
and I think it's gonna be one of those
options that take the primaries place
and people don't realize it
yeah it's a possibility but we gonna
move on future if it does happen is it
like Tim said it would have to be a
superior experience to local hardware
and it's like it's like seeing is all
this is coming from local hardware from
somewhere in the world that day is far
away no no no so let's get into the next
one which is about Scarlett and
specifically Lockhart and anaconda you
know we can we know that they're
prepping almost like a dual prong
approach and we have ps5 coming so I
want to talk about that and we're gonna
set this off with actually boom and I
need to know about that I know you feel
very strongly about you know anaconda
and its position but as well as Lockhart
but like what what are you feeling about
that strategy and then maybe how they
approach that launch so Lord boom let's
talk let's talk that scarlet talk real
quick you know the I think again we have
to rewind it back a bit I think that if
you go back to e3 2017
I feel Spencer a really did catch Sony
with their pants down so to speak with
thee we're announcing the s and then
they and in and in the same sentence
they announced the ex you know it was a
new new two new systems within a year of
each other and they would get you know
they were making the Xbox platform
affordable for people who wants to stick
with the ex but if you wanted power
which a lot of us do you went out more
the next year later and I bought an S
when it came out and I put an X when it
came out the next year I think what
Microsoft is doing right now
by offering two new consoles at the same
time again that's what we're thinking
that they're gonna release around the
same time it's giving options to gamers
and you know with everything they're
doing it again you have to look back to
what they're doing you know game pass
right now over 200 plus games in that
for $10 a month and if you're a savvy
person like myself you wait for Amazon
to have a sale will you buy it with you
gets free months free right so you can
literally get an entire year for half
price so if you're new to the Xbox
platform
you're late again this is not trying
what they're trying to do is not take
Sony players away from Sony that's not
what they're doing they want people to
own multiple consoles so maybe someone
who has a Sony it has a PlayStation 4
Pro and that's where they that's where
they love that's all that they use
that's great but Microsoft is gonna now
give an option for if you want the power
you're gonna spend the $500 which is
what we think that it's gonna be but if
you want to just kind of dip your toe in
to see if you like what you're seeing
you get the cheaper version now what
we're hearing is that the Xbox Lockhart
is slightly more powerful than the ex
okay so you are getting two
next-generation consoles one is gonna be
specifically priced for people who have
never invested in Xbox and may want to
do that and you have the one for the
diehard game with everybody on this
panel who what will go out and buy an
anaconda so I think what they're doing
is marketing genius one of the one of
their biggest fail points this
generation has been their lack of
marketing and messaging and I think that
we're starting to see there's gonna be a
change coming in the next generation no
doubt no doubt lower dealer I need some
strategy - - are they confusing the
market lured dealer these two consoles
I'm confused
well they certainly I'm confused by the
multiple different levels of displays in
my house the console power that I
already have in my house at different
phones in my house it's also confusing
it's not like it just turn it on and it
just works and I know exactly what the
hell I bought and it all cost different
prices for different reasons there's a
reason this OLED cost a lot more than
the KSR in the other room right so I
don't think it's confusing I think
that's a cop-out for people that are
short-sighted I also do not think
Lockhart is going to be faster than the
X and I on the GPU side I've said this
perform over over it'll be around four
or five teraflops on the GPU side but
it'll have improved CPU cores and
pasture ram and overall the goal of that
system in my opinion 100% should be be
as cheap as possible yeah
oh yes one ask Francis right and that
means maybe get rid of the disk drive do
well the Xbox one sad edition right you
should redesign that around new silicon
new power supply everything new
circuitry and got that down another
fifty bucks at least so that that should
be the goal of the lot card it should be
three hundred bucks and that thing
should I think should be an overall
better experience it's because it's
better overall the GPU slightly slower
but overall it's much better than the X
and then they'll phase the X out anakata
comes in they're like you know what
we're gonna double the power of the
issue and we're on double the power of
the X with the new rising cores and more
RAM and blah blah blah is D the way the
Lockhart's should not have an SSD is
they're gonna keep this thing as quick
as father as cheap as possible very
well-made but if you're training you
need to stop act like you buying that
car for fun all the super said don't
forget stadia is linux-based yes because
you got to develop every game for stadia
you don't get the competition isn't
doing that they're like look you got 35
under titles from day one boom updated
it works everywhere boom it's on every
device boom and stadiums over there with
you know they have to make every game
and optimize it just for stadia and
that's a massive disadvantage but in
terms of the whole purpose a la carte
every single bit of it should be to be
as cheap as possible as appealing as
possible otherwise to SKUs there's no
purpose there's no point if it's 400
bucks there's no point this 100 bucks
same price to be is 5
there's no point mmm right the whole
purpose is be as cheap as possible give
you access to a better experience well
they ain't a condom
double the power of the ex all the
goodies blah blah blah prices are really
nearly the option the thing that you got
to worry about so I'm really looking
forward to what they're doing here I've
been talking about that hold that
particular thing for a while and I'm
excited about the prospect of what could
be a far less compromised experience
right I think the ray-tracing as I've
said before is definitely a thing
minecraft 4 is a definitely be some
minecraft I know
they're working on him that will have
retracing and they're really gonna show
off some of this stuff I'm just really
excited about what they're gonna show
this year man thanks max give me some
ideas here I want to lock this down I
agree I agree Lord Sandman what are you
thinking about these two prong approach
with the console I'm getting excited
you know I'm thinking like wow like they
have so much potential the choices they
made here to make two consoles possibly
but unlikely to be two designs the the
the way they went about it I think was
really great so they went they want to
be the most powerful they want to ensure
that and I'm pretty sure that that
story's going to be fleshed out at e3
hopefully and this all comes to fruition
what we've been saying is going to
happen this obviously it hasn't happened
yet but all the key to show that so they
got that down they that that was huge
for Xbox and and for me that's that
that's as a fan that's that's huge
that's like big to me I don't I think
that they have to be in the $4.99 range
but I'm not sure that's one of the
questions I have but the Lockhart
yeah like dealer said if they're gonna
go after market that's the ones who sell
the most
ya know the talk about the guy that's
gonna sell the most and they give them
the $2.99 area and it does 1080 K 60
with ray tracing and you know all types
of bells and whistles I do believe that
paceman might be where it's it's a it's
gonna land now when they say 11.1 based
on Navi technology maybe a dealer can
you know say it better but there's
something called like RT n or TRS which
is the equivalent of the Vega
architecture and if you compare the two
you like air to t flops so it's like
really you're getting like a 13.5 Vega
right you know around that speed but
even though I that's what I think it's
gonna think I think both Sounion
and-and-and xbox will be pretty close
but I think Xbox gonna
I've walked e-file welcome self right to
him last e3 we're gonna once again we're
gonna continue and be the benchmark for
console gaming mean we got the most
performance right a lot of people think
well you got a big Akari on a Polaris
card it is possible to have a faster
last generation architecture card than a
newer generation card right like if I
want to go to an RT X car or a newer GT
X card there are faster older variants
of those cards on all their
architectures for instance right mmm so
just because you're on Vega and and I'm
on Polaris like in an ideal world they
have cards where they've made players
cars faster than whatever an older
architecture that's much more expensive
just because you're newer doesn't mean
you're faster automatically for one so I
don't really care what architecture
they're using as long as the seven
nanometer they need power drawn heat
that's absolutely essential when you're
pumping out this kind of power and
really will suit kind of features that
comes with like Bega came with delta
color compression with the xbox one i
actually get some features there that
it's a mesh of the two and likely you'll
have a mesh of these architectures with
the next consoles as well absolutely i
mean lord adequate louis go know what he
feel about that la chorus i'm targeting
you i think that they're going to really
just promote the what's the higher the
anaconda i think they'll briefly talk
about the lion head or lion heart or
whatever that's called but you know i
think for the most part they're gonna
they're gonna promote the higher tier
one the most but they are going to make
you their aware that the other one
exists it's just they're gonna want the
highlight being around the handicar
that's the best experience yeah yeah and
you know i think it's gonna be one of
those things how king says it you know
we got the premium experience here but
you know we know you bro people
[Laughter]
we got that's what you got you got it
yeah what this do I don't mean you have
gone at it on this year definitely I
mean I love the two-prong approach I
think and that's in that way they say
they make sure that they don't lose that
power narrative ever again
they make sure they have all their bases
covered like I said before I think the
Lockhart is what's most important for
them I think anaconda is the boutique
item that we all want whatever that
means it's gonna be the high-end
boutique thing and I think that that
lock car is really where the sales are
gonna be made and for me it comes down
to you know we said it before the secret
sauce that these are these count so as
utilized I think the Lockhart whatever
optimizations are made to that like
dealer we're saying to make it uh to
make it as cheap as possible but at the
same time as powerful as possible to be
able to to be able to throw around all
of these you know these these coin terms
these ray-tracing and be able to do all
of that at as lower price as possible I
think is to me staple it off is gonna be
the most impressive thing and to me it's
what they have to do if they really want
to push the Xbox brand in the console
space folder they don't care about the
console space that in that way anymore
they just care about the ecosystem then
then then fine but for the Lockhart to
for Xbox as a brand in to compete with
with Sony's name in the console space
this Lockhart it has to be comparable in
price and empower and appeal yes I think
that that's one of the reasons I do
think that they're going to really focus
on the higher-end one I think they're
gonna mainly resort to you know the
people that go around and make sure
their products are being pushed the
correct way that they want them to and
then if you think about commercials and
everything what did they say at the end
of commercials Oh on xbox like they
don't really go on even with the
and the s if they ever came out both
better on the X and slightly worse
that's like that's why I believe this
narrative the people go around saying
it's confusing how like it's not like
they've ever promoted both consoles in
the same maybe those people are the ones
confused then they like it is everyone
this is everyone this way the way you
think like they're confused no one
else's we don't have different levels
and price points for TVs in a cart
oh look forward the X all about the X
the iPhone X has like three different
versions of it what a bigger hard drive
like at the end of the day it's like I
said does the iPhone go around promoting
every iPhone they have no they promote
the best one that's on the market and
you Reb could go to the store and get
recommended the other cheap one are you
going it lets us solve you finish
already get kinging yeah the problem
with that is that at the at the core
level right at the at the street level
when you go into a store how confident
are you they say you don't know anything
about this stuff you don't know what we
know you walk into a store how confident
are you that the person telling you
about this console knows what the hell
they're talking about within there you
know what you know what does all the
talking is that extra 200 bucks in
between the two that's true that's
better
thanks thanks Lord King are you confused
how you feel about this 2.0 prong
approach
I love the way dealer put stuff you know
I watch a channel for their technical
aspect that um I might not know certain
things like he told you the seven
nanometer is definitely necessary other
people won't key in on that right um and
he gave you why right now and he did say
that that disk drive should be
eliminated so if let's say the lockhardt
does come in with no disk drive right
then the whole sad edition that was
launched makes a little bit more sense
right and you see the price point made a
little bit more sense because if the
lock core comes in at this
price point as I said their feeds inside
out right and they bring the lock card
in at that price point in like dealer
said yeah like dealer said I do not
believe they lock hard will be more
powerful than X okay well I believe
it'll be more capable than X cpu-bound
damn right and I don't believe it it'd
be more powerful the bushes we got give
it right exactly so ran right got two
kilos really I believe everything is
factual right hey now going on to the
boutique items like sovereign said um is
anaconda everybody on this panel we are
we're and not saying that people aren't
true gamers right we when we say we're
true gamers this is a distinction
between somebody that's an audiophile
and somebody that likes speakers facts
okay when you go into a store and I
spend five to six thousand on a bowl
system it's because I want to hear that
little ping in the corner when I throw a
quarter in my game right I want to hear
that ping you buy a sound bar because
you don't give a dag about that ping you
really just care about a nice sound
coming at you and you don't care what
direction is coming at Oh sound like
it's around whatever this is the same
thing here when we want this boutique
item is because we want the bells in the
whistles we want all the power we want
to look over and say I'm better than you
right now Phil Phil's that way when
you're getting askew
that is one is cheaper to get in those
guys who feel like I don't have this
much money or and I still want to play
with it with everybody else I want to be
a part of the next generation I'm coming
in with a lower aspect that's how Sony
won the narrative they're more more
powerful and cheaper
alright the deficit of the finalists
shadowlord's the III feel Dominus
and then you have you know the anaconda
where it's going to be a little bit more
right alright and we we expect that we
expect a little bit more we expect that
premium going inside the store
we don't see 300 when we walk in the
store we see 600 and I honestly believe
it's gonna be $600 um I see $600 welcome
if they come in at 5:00 that's a smash
that is a smash all right if you get a
price point come on I don't think we get
a price one coming at ec3
but if $600 is that thing I don't care
anyway it's out there too with the
Lockhart I think it will be $2.99 if
they're smart to go that direction and
if the whole point of the Lockhart is to
be the cheapest entry they could
possibly get it down to PS five comes at
400 I'll be a little bit more powerful
of course considerably more powerful a
bigger gap between the S the peaceful
pro in the X for sure but don't be
surprised that Lockhart doe got
retreating now whoa but that's the right
that's the money and not only that
four-five teraflops it's not enough
overhead to do a ton of stuff a rate
raising especially it good frame rates
so you know to get it down as low as
possible they may skip it on that one
and also that block before that's gonna
do ray tracing right they could use that
for like physics and other things as
well then people aren't really talking
physics is massive I did a video on that
it's not just about ray tracing the
smart these will be multi function cores
that can do more than just ray tracing
you know they need that they need
to kind of have that that physics action
going on right language sir Gilliam
acres of good points no I mean listen
King you own it because at the end you
said you would check it out check it out
you can ease back because I got your
knees in this box you can get your knees
back because let me tell you something
when you see the price tag are you going
to store it you know say that's what
your while ago start talking to you
that's your Prague you can do but you've
always said 4k was like ruination that's
because the X came out way after the one
I had yeah look what it did I know a
good position I mean yeah you might get
30 frames but you know you're gonna get
four we ask yes you bar about that on
the show right like we asked him about
is the X gonna be viable in a year or
two he said yeah a hundred percent
things still cuz I've done a punch a ton
of options and settings and it's very
capable just bottlenecks at 30fps
exactly many cases many yeah Bob it'll
still have really the worst thing
because I mean listen I know deal is
nuts about first I don't gonna be
sometimes you can see frames but most of
times I don't care
Tim you can always see frames to be like
if it's 30 frames per second
I grew up these games and they used to
pause I am NOT hey Tim yeah I get it
you're fine with 30 frames when you boot
up rage what did you notice a hundred
percent of times some cases it's like
that now imagine they're 60 FPS though
like why not have it if you can do it
why not do it it makes it it makes a
great game even better yeah it's like if
you don't care about 16 and don't spend
the money on well the thing about these
consoles Tuesday speed you know Sonia
ratio that off and and I know I said the
thing that I heard the three-second
thing from boot from cold boot you're in
your you why you're right into your
thing so well the speed of these things
is gonna be so much faster
they don't were used to the UI that we
complain about a lot of that it's just
the speed that's gonna be so interesting
to find out the Lockhart has and
that's gonna be I have to say that I
played with a guy who has a regular
smegal xbox right and I got a Smigiel Oh
a circular a white joint alright he
shout out to him he works for Microsoft
not gonna throw you in the bushes and he
has a smuggler and he went and got a SSD
we play destiny together you're left
behind
yeah hello name faster than you I'm so
mad that I paid for this X and this dude
is runnin around in the world he's like
y'all gotta have two enemies kill
spaceship he already got have to strike
done yeah so no no this is a good
discussion Tim I think you're making a
good point you know at the end of the
day like I said the LA car is gonna be
very interested me how they position
that bad boy and then like Dylan said we
gotta talk about placing the farm in the
sense that if they're aggressive let's
just say they happen to be aggressive
and they mimic what they did last gen
and come in at that 400 then the pricing
gets even more interesting for Lockhart
because I think to me that again the
balance has to be drawn there the
hardcore the enthusiasts like King is
saying the booty guys like we're getting
that and it kind of neurotic supposedly
but uh you know at the end of the day we
gotta see how that's gonna do and I
think you know Lockhart if they can
achieve that 1080 60 at that cheap of
high price point and get that down
demographic they will be fine
so what we gonna get into the big dog
topic this hot takes you know we got the
Brazilian leak that's come out they
saying that they have allotted two hours
for this show you know Easton we're
right on the cusp of it I'm gonna set
this off with Lord Sandman I mean so mic
drop moments for you or just some spicy
takes down one get you excited about
this brief and let's go what I want okay
this is what I want a studio bad I don't
think we might get it but I want a
studio a bad I want a segment with that
hopefully that's the new game I want
them to say that they're gonna be the
most powerful because I'm paying like I
want like let's be honest if we're gonna
be real here sometimes people have a
problem doing that power does matter
you wanna bring in console you didn't
want the most powerful thing it's like
you when you buy a Lamborghini and you
buy a Maserati you guys say well what's
the HP which which one you like you know
like the first one the bottom line is
that they have to deliver I'm expecting
to deliver expecting them to have a
great week I'm expecting to be jumping
for joy I'm confident that that's most
likely gonna happen or anything they
have so much stuff ready to go but those
are the two big things I want games and
I want people that's the oh those are my
three asks addict is loving you I want
the fable I want it you know what it's
already these articles right now yeah
it's ready out of the bag just you know
what it's a surprise that everyone's
best known speaker whatever so secret I
have that stupid saying goes but that's
what I want you know what I know III
want people there because it's a
bonafide trip away and you have gears Oh
blow our socks off I guess it's gonna be
I think you see some stuff on the other
with the new engine we're gonna blow our
socks off and then you're gonna have
fable with playground I don't think you
get much but you might get something
that really intrigues you and for me
that's you know listen that might be low
by early students but that's what I'm ok
with it now if they want to put it into
other surprises I'm hoping that the
ninja game means a theory look scheme as
pointed out by dealer and others it is
they're they're not their frontline team
it is a team that was working on this
behind like it's not the hell-blade team
which is pretty much the the
unbelievable panel that's do they're not
saying that this is their band I don't
know they're kind of a question mark but
I hope they I hope that game looks
really good ok buddy they sounded a
better public I need over there sick
darkwing duck
Bob out here baby crispy bosses URI no
dude look at their completely going away
from the theme of over here okay and we
will hear some of that now knows exactly
how that crowd is about to get lit and
he knows me starting right and I really
wanted to be all that I really wanted to
drive home and and say you know they did
a great job they want III and I think
they're going to do it but this is the
possibility that they want this
possibility you have a pop and feeling
Oh
I want that gears though that's the you
this this is the problem with everybody
gonna be this talk of the shower I mean
I can't wait to see what's what rod has
in store
[Laughter]
Oh Lord oh I need you brother no here's
the thing
for me personally I that they are in
position where most of community